joining me now delighted he's with us
former Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
distinguished fellow at the Hudson
Institute and Fox News contributor Mr
secretary I think more than anything
else here that is disturbing is this
lack of accountability which really
offends me most given what's at stake
it's pretty remarkable Laura you hear
President Biden talk about uh we're back
that America is back it does feel like
it feels like 1976 1979 right people are
not being told to turn down the
thermostat we're being told that we're
not going to have enough energy we're
not being told that to solve the
economic problems we're going to have to
lay off hundreds of thousands of
Americans get unemployment up to five or
six percent to solve this problem and
every family in America can feel that
and when it comes to our national
security we we lost the bubble we lost
the deterrence that we had for four
years we're the Bad Guys Xi Jinping
Vladimir Putin the Taliban they
understood that they couldn't do what
they've done to America these lasting 18
months and I think every American your
point about Unity I think every American
not Republicans not Democrats every
American can feel that they are less
secure less safe that their borders are
under threat that crime is higher those
are those are things that come just
shoot just four weeks from now when
people start voting in the midterms I
think the American people are going to
reject exactly what it is President
Biden has given them
um here was Biden today
um secretary Pompeo touting one of his
really big priorities at the UN watch
my Administration is working with our
Congress to deliver more than 11 billion
dollars a year
to International climate Finance
to help lower income countries Implement
their climate goals and ensure a Just
Energy transition
now Mr secretary we are wasting more
money on projects that do nothing to
keep this country safe nothing
everyone remembers solyndra it seems
like history just repeating itself from
the Obama years or the Carter years
where where we take taxpayer money and
give it to some slush front leftist to
do something that will have no value for
the American people
we can see it we have trapped American
Energy in the ground this was a deeply
political decision the president today
kind of kind of said the quiet part out
loud in a speech he talked about the
inflation reduction act but said oh this
is the biggest climate project in
American history this is bad for the
American people it's dangerous for our
security I am confident that there's not
a family in America who thinks that was
a good idea or will serve their own
family well
the Citibank CEO appeared at a
congressional hearing today and she was
answering a question about decoupling
from China which is something you and I
have talked about a lot
watch what she says here
when we look at the clients that we
serve many of them are multinational
clients in China and we see that there
is a high degree of interdependence
we've got to take a strategic view in
America as to where it is that we need
more strategic Independence and to build
that in a thoughtful manner but also in
a way that doesn't cause uh crises
economic crises
okay so Jane Frazier there Mr secretary
she doesn't want to pull back from China
because they have a lot of Chinese
clients I I just did the quick summation
of what she said
that's a pretty good summary Laura one
that you and I have heard from Big
Finance uh here in the United States for
an awfully a long time I will tell you
it also sounds an awful lot what I heard
from Chinese leaders Chinese leadership
saying oh we're so connected it'll be
really bad for you this is precisely the
wrong headed thinking that for 40 years
didn't recognize that the Chinese
Communist party has declared economic
war on America they spilled their
economy on the back of America and we
allowed them to do it I hope our senior
Financial leaders will begin to truly
understand that they are American
companies with American interests and do
the things that will defend American
freedom and put real pressure on the
Chinese Communist party to begin to
behave
yeah no no they said today oh we're we
don't which is true they said we don't
make policy but we we consult with the
US government I think it was Jamie dimon
who might have said that today
um so I mean so but but they're making
it clear like you can't decouple because
that would cause two molds and what I'd
say to Jamie dimon is you wanted Biden
and now you got Biden how does it feel
feel good Jamie yeah
and and don't forget Laura when Congress
attempted to put some pressure on China
about their human rights violations the
uyghur ACT uh the banks lobbied against
it they went to Capitol Hill and said
this is a bad idea to protect human
rights to say they don't shape policy
make policy and impact America is just
silly
disgusting uh Mr secretary great to see
you tonight thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else